أنا في كييف الآن وهي تتعرض
للهجوم السيد لافروف من القوات الروسية
وأود أن أعرف ما هي خطتك
لقيادة هذا البلد ،
هل تنوي قطع رأس
قيادة هذا البلد لماذا القوات الروسية
الآن؟  دخول كييف
المحيطة بالعاصمة والقتال مع الجيش الأوكراني ،
هل تنوي قطع رأس
القيادة الأوكرانية ، هل يمكنك أن تعطيني
إجابة بسيطة من فضلك
سيدي سيهاجم شعب أوكرانيا ،
لن يقوم أحد بطريقة ما
بإضعاف القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
التي نتحدث عنها
منع النازيين الجدد
وأولئك الذين
يروجون للإبادة الجماعية
من حكم هذا البلد لأن
النظام الحالي في كييف
يخضع لآليتي تحكم خارجيتين
الأولى الغرب والولايات المتحدة
والثانية النازية الجديدة أولئك الذين
يفرضون
ثقافتهم وهي مزدهرة في أوكرانيا
اليوم لمشاعرك.  بما أن شخصًا ما في
كييف في هذه اللحظة بالذات ،
سأشدد على قراءة ما قاله بوتين ،
لا ضربات على البنية التحتية المدنية ،
لا توجد
ضربات على  أفراد
الجيش الأوكراني في
مهاجعهم أو في أماكن أخرى غير
متصلة بالمنشآت العسكرية
جيدًا لا قصف على
البنية التحتية المدنية أو الجيش
نظرًا للوضع الذي نشهده على الرغم من أنني
لا أعرف كيف أم كيف أه كيف
يمكن أن نكون مطمئنين  أه من تصريحات
وزير الخارجية الروسي يمكنني
إخبارك أن الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
أه إنه قلق للغاية
على أمنه الخاص أدلى بتصريح
أمس على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي قال فيه إنه
يصدق العدو الذي يقصد به
روسيا بالطبع
جعله الهدف الأول
في البلاد وجعلوا عائلته
الهدف الثاني ولذا فهو
يتخذ الاحتياطات مثل كبار
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين الآخرين في حال
كانت الخطوة التالية للقوات الروسية ليست
مجرد محاصرة  عاصمة
اوكرانيا ولكن احضر وانتم تعلمون كما
ذكرت هناك لاسقاط القيادة
واستبدالها بنظام الموالية لموسكو
وهو مصدر قلق كبير لها.  البريد
جون